so how can you get started with r and
python
here we have the omics logic playground
all you need to do
is click on get started for free you
log in using your account or you create
an account right here
let me sign in and start off with the
very first
module getting started with
bioinformatics in r
if we click here you'll see a brief
overview of why we started the code
playground
and you have the first several lessons
that you can start working on
just read about the code and then try to
do it yourself
importing and viewing a text file
let's run it error running code why is
that
we need to read the instructions let's
copy this link
replace it here let's
clear and run it again all right
great now we're successful let's keep on
going
here's some excel files csvs etc try
some other ones
once you complete this lesson go back to
all the courses
now we can visualize this data let's try
to visualize
now there's many different types of data
categorical
continuous so let's read about how to
work with such data let's try it
yourself so here we're working with the
gene expression table
we can replace this link again let's run
it
if something goes wrong and i've messed
up i just need to press here
run it and the answer is correct
so the data set that we were loading
here was much smaller 14
rows by 52 samples
now we can take this data and visualize
it we can make
a box plot here we have a heat map
or a histogram let's change something
instead of red let's make it orange
all right great so now we're getting
farther along and so forth as you
continue through the courses you will
see how your skills will improve
you will understand different types of
data different methods
you'll learn how to code and eventually
you can take this off
from this playground onto your computer